une grande première au domaine de
dampierre en yvelines un salon sur les
thèmes de l'art et du jardin était
programmé pendant trois jours dans le
parc
une centaine d'exposants spécialisés
dans les plantes ou le milieu artistique
a pris place sur le site
c'est une rencontre avec le public les
professionnels avec le public c'est une
rencontre avec l'amour du jardin avec
l'amour de l'art l'occasion pour ce
domaine du xviie siècle de renouer avec
son histoire
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
important pour le domaine de dampierre
puisque dampierre c'est l'art des
jardins par excellence puisque de tout
temps il ya eu des jardins qui ont été
aménagés autour du château et de
recevoir une fête des jardins une fête
des plantes est une fête de l'art des
jardins
c'est exactement ça c'est un privilège
pour rendre hommage au parc paysager de
dompierre en yvelines dessiné par andré
le nôtre un jardin de 300 mètres carrés
avaient été spécialement conçu pour
l'événement s'agira mix entre un jardin
à la française un jardin à l'italienne
avec leur mélange un petit peu des
choses des parties très structurée des
parties un petit peu sauvage au total
plusieurs milliers de visiteurs sont
venus sur ce site pendant ce rendez-vous
arrêt jardin c'est ça me semble très
très complémentaire à dire culture et
culture d'une part puis d'autre part je
connais déjà certains exposants et les à
me fait plaisir de les voir on aime bien
les expositions on aime bien l'art il ya
de très jolies sculptures on a trouvé
notre bonheur
on a ravi une nouvelle édition de ce
salon arts et jardins pourraient être
organisées l'année prochaine vu le
succès rencontré cette année